So now that we know, we saw what happens under
the hood, and as I said, don't worry about it if
you don't care about that part. Now we can go back
to Eclipse, and we can start creating a package. A package
is basically a way of organizing your classes into a
hierarchy. In this case, I'm going to specify the package name as
edu.gatech, which means that I'm creating really two packages, a package
gatech inside package edu. And I can start creating classes inside
my packages. So here, I can use the contextual menu, select
New>Class, and I'll get another wizard that will allow me to
specify the name of the class. I'm not very creative here,
so I'm just going to call it Hello World. There's many other parameters
you can set, and in particular, you can define whether you
want a main method in your class. Where having a main
method means that your class can be the main class in
your project, can be the one that is run when you run
your project. After we click the button, the Finish button, we,
we get the class. So we also get template code for the
class, as you can see here, so we go to the editor
function, you can see that there is a to do. Where you
have to put your code, and here we are simply, basically printing,
you know, the typical first program. We just going to print Hello World
in Java. And something you can note is that as we are
typing, Eclipse gives us a auto complete suggestions, which is very helpful.
For example, in case you don't remember the exact syntax,
or the method, or you don't remember the parameters of the
method. Which is, you know, often the case especially where you
work with large libraries. So having that feature can really, really
help you. So now if we want to run our code
we can either click on the button up here, or we
can right-click in the Call window and select Run As Java
Application. And if we do that, Eclipse will run our tool,
and it will create, as you can see here, a console view that basically contains
the textual output of my program. And as expected, the output is Hello World.